i am okay great well let me uh introduce
i want to uh welcome everyone to our
thursday
the mice research informatics research
conference
and we have a speaker who
is relatively new to ohsu but is working
on a very
interesting and important project that
ohsu
has some significant involvement in
the n3c project the national
covid cohort collaborative project
which is an initiative of of
nih the national institutes of health it
is
um administered by the national center
for advancing translational sciences or
ncats it's part of the ctsa program
which ohsu has been part of for many
years
and um this project came about obviously
in response to the covid19 pandemic
anita walden is an instructor
in d mice she is also
the assistant director of the
clinical data to health project which is
the part of
ncats that is overseeing the n3c
uh project she has worked in informatics
for a number of years she
uh previously held informatics research
positions at duke
university and university of arkansas
she has a master's degree in
biomedical informatics from the
university of texas houston
and has really been running the day to
day operations of n3c which
i personally find is a very exciting
project
and in fact i already have one master
student who
is involved in using data from the
project
so i won't i could go on and on but i
won't take any further
um of anita's time she will uh give us
an overview
of the project and hopefully um we'll
have a little time for a q a
um when she finishes her talk so go
ahead anita
all right thank you so very much thank
you can everyone see my screens okay
you see the slides yeah we can see them
fine we can hear you fine
perfect perfect all right hello everyone
um thank you so much for the opportunity
to talk to you about
this enormous effort um the national
covet collaborative um npc and i want to
talk to you about the opportunities
that are available um before we do that
um i wanted to give you a brief overview
of n3c um since we first started it
i'm going to tell you about where we are
now and then
opportunities for not just faculty but
for students and staff as well
and then how to engage with n3c
so um as bill mentioned though um before
we start with you
about cd2h this is this national center
for data to help
and it's the coordinating center is here
at ohsu in our own backyard
um melissa hendell is the pi and i am
the assistant director
and so we're really thrilled to be you
know to work with um
ohsu and um oak tree and those
organizations here
and the whole purpose of cd2h for those
who don't know
is that it's really designed to
accelerate informatics here
across the ctsas and if you don't know
what ctsas are those are the clinical
translational
science award sites these are the
academic medical centers across the
united states
so it was designed in order to help
create tools and
resources and methods to facilitate
facilitate
translational research across the
network so that's
that's the reason why i was designed but
a little bit more about the direction of
informatics and innovation
so if you talk to somebody nih one of
the reasons
why cdth was designed is because we're
going to build
an infrastructure where organizations
are sharing resources and tools
across the ctsas but across nih in
general
so instead of one site creating a tool
that's only used at one site we're going
to be able to create tools that can be
used by multiple sites
also as you're also as you're probably
aware is that there's an increased
use or requirement or
desire to use ehr data for research
and so we're trying to figure out ways
in order to facilitate that
um through interoperability across the
ctsas and across
academic medical centers and this is
done through common data models and
national standards
um one of national standards that's
really taken off right now
is one that she's across hospitals
nationwide and that's health level seven
um anytime you're receiving lab
information a lot of times they're using
the standard called hl7
well there's another standard at hs7
called fire
and that has a lot of excitement right
now and so the
the research community is really
interested in using fire so they
developed a
accelerator at um h07 it's called
vulcan and that accelerator is to
enhance that standard for the purpose of
clinical research
so that way we can actually exchange
information um
not just within our organizations but
across organizations
the other direction that's taking place
right now is that
you know we want to make sure that we're
doing research
that is scalable usable that is
impactful
especially across large populations we
do a lot of small
projects with 50 100 200 patients
but now we want to start doing things on
broader scale with thousands of patients
and really see how things work
um and then we want to demonstrate value
so if there's research we're doing
we want to figure out you know what kind
of value is that
and and the impact on innovation on our
patients and on health care
and one of the other things that i think
you've seen increase
is around team science and so this
the nih is interested in team science
because they think that
together with different people from
diverse backgrounds and different roles
can come up with innovative solutions
that might be a little bit more
challenging if you have only physicians
their own epidemiologist on a team
so these are some of the directions and
and where
research is moving towards and that's
the reason why organizations like cb2h
have been established
so one of the things we want to be able
to do with m3c
is be able to answer different types of
questions and actually before i talk
about some of the questions let me talk
a little bit more about
m3c and the way it's designed so
right now a lot of times what happens is
that
you can do what's called federated query
and that is you have a question that a
centralized group is asking
they send that question to the different
organizations they come up with the
answer
they send an answer back to the
centralized group and that group
combines
all the answers from all the different
organizations and and come up with an
answer and so
that's when the data you know stays
local doesn't go anywhere
um and you can answer questions such as
you know how much time
you know um can someone stay on a
ventilator if they use a certain type of
drug
what n3c is doing though is more
centralized analytics and that means the
data is in a central
central location you could do a little
bit more than you can with a federated
period essential
central query and so one of the things
you can do with centralized analytics
is use use different types of tools and
do more predictive factors so in this
kit in this example here
you know what are the predictive um
factors um
regarding severe outcomes for kovid so
this is the reason why we took this
approach for npc
um data is an essential location um
versus in a
federated location and so
we decided that you know instead of
everybody just sending this their data
we want to do it in
a common format and so we have four
models to choose from
we have act we have um omop for
coordinate
and we have trinetics and so most
academic organizations across the
country
are using one of these for and this
makes it easier for us
so they can pick either one of these and
send us their data any one of these
using one of these data models um from
there
we are taking these four and harmonize
them to one data model which is oma
and um and so that's what we decided to
do
and and in order to do that though we
had to set up
work streams in order to develop this
infrastructure
so starting first with data partnership
and governance
we actually had to make decisions as far
as how best to actually share that
information and share data
and pop and develop and create the
policies and procedures around that
and then we have the phenotype and data
acquisition this is the group that
developed the phenotype of covet
and they're working directly with the
sites in order to get the data
into npc and so if any of you guys have
been working
with um the work here with the data here
at ohsu
know that this group is very hands-on
they're very helpful
um they'll do anything they can to
assist
with getting your data into the um in 3c
environment
then once the data has been brought into
the environment
there are data quality checks that are
run on the data and
you know and most people do a really
good job with submitting your data but
sometimes they're things you may not
realize like
we did receive data that where directly
covert
patients that was the whole purpose of
our study so we had to go back and ask
them to add the code of patients
um so they take every data quality
checks
and then after the data quality checks
have been run on the data
then they start to harmonize that data
with the omop model
and when they do that there's also
another set of quality checks that are
run too
and they work with the sites if they
have to add or make any changes
so once it's gone through that data
quality pipeline
um that we establish then it's placed
into the enclave
and when it's placed into the enclave
there's another step there's a synthetic
step
and so with the data that's placed into
the enclave there's synthetic data a
derivative of that data
that's been created and that's right now
it's a pilot we'll talk a little bit
more a little bit later about the
synthetic data but it is a pilot project
people are really not sure exactly how
synthetic data works
how it's going to impact research uh and
that's what we're here to do we're here
to you know look at the research around
that so they're actually the process of
validating
the data now and we hope to have the
validation done sometime um
in the next month or so so this is the
pipeline of the data
that's been established and so basically
i'm going to go back we're hoping
that with this data we can answer
questions
uh we can answer questions such as you
know
predicting who might have severe
outcomes from covet 19 because those
things we don't know to really know the
answer to just yet
also if you have a rare disease it's an
opportunity
because you have more data to look at
those rare observations
and then you can also do a comparison
how does your
local data compare nationally with the
national outcomes
and then there's also questions we want
to be able to answer around um social
determinants of health so that seems to
be a factor
when it comes to covet 19.
so what is in the n3c data well this is
the interesting question
um and we and i'll tell you the reason
why it's interesting
but for the most part what we have here
is what we're receiving
and we're not just looking for the data
in a point in time
so we're not just asking people to just
send us your covert data
but we want to get information about any
devices or other conditions that they
have
um and we're looking at data not just
for you know that particular visit but
we're looking for data two years back so
we're asking sites
for a patient that has been tested for
or suspected to have coveted or tested
for covet
to provide data about observations any
other specimens and procedures they
might have had
um from this state two years back and so
um that's what we're doing now um if you
want more information
about the actual phenotype you can find
the phenotype listed on our website and
the definitions for that which icd codes
are using
uh it will change we are looking at a
different version of the phenotype now
that we have more information about
covet
we're making some changes to it so if
you think back early in march
in april we didn't know very much about
covet
and there weren't the codes that were in
ehr for covet
um people were you know using all
different types of
um clinical onset information about
the disease and so that's what we've
been using but now people have a good
idea about how to define covate
and so that's just where we're gonna
change the phenotype for that but the
reason why i say this is interesting
about what's in
n3c data because it does depend on the
data model
so the data four data models were
designed for
different reasons and different purposes
so they're not all like they don't all
collect the same information
so um you know for omap you may have
certain things that are in there they're
not in for quarry
so that's just something to note that if
you're using the data and you notice
there might be gaps it could be because
the pcori data model or trinity collect
a different information than omar
so there will be differences across the
sites depending on which data model they
use
all right so a little bit about the
enclave people have asked me why do you
call
the the data enclave data enclave why
don't you call it the data set
well it's much more than the covet data
set um the onclaim is really a secure
analytic platform that includes a lot of
different factors a lot of different
things
is fedramp compliant it resides on the
intcat servers and it's an environment
that includes the m3c
data coming from the sites across the
country but it also includes tools
um and we'll talk about some of the
tools in the moment includes tools
um but you also can perform your
analytics nothing leaves the
nothing leaks the enclaves so you do all
your analytics within the aqua you use
your tools in there
you perform your analytics you come up
with your research um
answers all in the all in the enclave
um the synthetic data is also in the
enclave
and then um you also build your data
sets
in your enclave so there's everything
that's done within the enclave
um and so that's the reason why we call
it a secure platform and it's more than
just the data set
so these are just some of the tools that
are in the enclave
in addition to what's in the enclave we
also hope to link to other data sets
we hope to link to imaging like covet
imaging
um and there will be external data sets
that will be available in the enclave
there are some of the main teams um and
clinical research teams that ask can we
include this other data sets this will
help
enhance our research and so we have a
process
where if you want to use an external
data set you make a request
it's reviewed by the governance team and
then it's um
and it was approved and it's implemented
into the enclaves and there's a way that
you can perform linkages
so there is a process for that so um but
there
these are some of the tools that are
available there are a lot of other tools
that are available
so you can always ask us if there are
additional tools
um and then there's a question about
well i have a tool can i implement that
tool and use it in your way
there are there's also a process for
that too first there's an evaluation of
that tool determine if
already exist or not and if it doesn't
exist there will be an evaluation
determine
you know if it's safe and secure to use
all right so we're going to talk now a
little bit about our progress
so um back in march when there was a lot
of this
when you know when the covid virus you
know first
you know blew up and everybody was kind
of in a panic
we were all we were all saying okay
we've got to figure out something we've
got to be able to answer questions
and we need to we need to do something
fast so
in march um melissa hendell
chris chu and king gerstein from incats
got together and said
we need to develop we need to build this
enclave that can be available for
researchers to use so they can
actually ask questions and find answers
and this all happened
really quickly uh so if you look at the
timeline here
so on in this timeline there was a
webinar when we first launched
that happened around april 13th when we
said this is what we've got this is what
we
are going to do and this is our plan and
you can find that webinar actually on
our website if you want to listen to it
and then right after that phenotype 1.0
was
was defined we created phenotype 1.0
this is the covert phenotype
um and then um there was a letter to the
ctsa steering committee
and the letter said to the spirit
committee you know there's this data set
that's being created um
this is what the nation needs let's do
this
and then right after that um the data
transfer agreements were finalized
and then john hopkins is a central irb
they got
that established and set up for
essential irb for this effort by may
so just think and just less than you
know
a little over the less than two weeks
from fears of the idea
to you know getting a phenotype we
already had irb set up there was a town
hall meeting
um with the ctsas but even before the
town hall meeting took place
the first data transfer agreement was
signed uh people
said i'm i'm up i'm going to join i want
to start sending my data um chris austin
had a town hall meeting
encouraging ctsas to participate and
right after that town hall meeting the
first data landed on our doorstep
so by may 12th um then between may 12
and august a lot of stuff happened we
had to build the infrastructure we had
to
design the pipeline we had to get all
the governance in place and all the
policies established
we had to design the data use request
process
so that way collaborate collaborators
and um
and investigators can submit their
projects we also had to set up the data
access committee at ncats to review
these requests and
it's all that took place within a short
amount of time and so by august 17th we
had our soft launch
where we opened up and tested the
process and so that's what we did
and the official soft launch when
everybody when it was announced for
every buyer was on september 2nd
so i mean this happened quickly i mean
we had
you know 16 20 hour days um we worked
every day
we didn't know what didn't know which
day it was but there was a lot of work
happening really fast
and the reason why this was able to be
done is because
we built this base off of the cd2h
infrastructure so a lot of this was
already in place
the relationships with the community
were already in place some of the
organizational structures were already
in place
where something like this probably would
have taken a couple years to design
we were able to do it in several months
so where are we today
well it's exciting that we have two
billion rows of data currently in the
enclave
we have two million patients in the
enclave
there are 72 data transfer agreements
have been executed that means 72 sites
have agreed
currently going on right now there are
58 projects
um they're 31 sites um that have data
and enclave at least
what's even more incredible is that
you know with cd2h there are over um
1200 people who have registered with c2h
representing over 300 organizations
in 14 foreign countries so this is just
not all just the ctsa there's so many
people
who see this as a valuable resource and
who are here
to help get it established and lifted up
as well as perform research
and these are just some current
statistics about what our
um cohort looks like right now and we
will have a cohort paper that's going to
come out
um really soon it's being offered right
now and so you'll get more information
once that paper
has been published but um just to give
you a little bit information about
you know about what we have here our
demographics
what is when we first started people
assume that you know as far as age group
that we'll see a lot of people in 65 and
plus
age group they'll have their in our data
set when really it's between 18 and 64
with 30 to 49 being the largest age
group that's in the data set
so the data transfer agreement in ohsu
so ohsu
is submitting data as i mentioned or
submitted submitting it using omap
um the oaktree group has been
responsible for that in a data warehouse
and so um we have our dta's executed and
signed
and also um ohsg was also the very first
data usage we've been assigned executed
as well
and so that means anybody here at ohsu
who has
a ohsu email address and that's very
important
well um can you can go into the enclave
and go ahead and start submitting your
projects and using the data
so we're excited that we're one of the
first and that it's a resource for ohsu
to participate in
and this is just a list of all the other
organizations who have duas that was as
of yesterday so you're asking why
what what's the benefit of m3c yeah what
it's a great
covid you know database um you know it's
access to large scale coded data
but what else is there well first of all
this data is not just ohsu data it's
data from across the nation
um also it's great for pilot data so if
you're looking for a grant proposal and
probably right about now nih is probably
granting
um money for research on covet 19
and so this could be really this could
be used for pilot day program proposals
it's a great opportunity for kl2 and tl1
scott and other scholars
it's also a good opportunity for team
science um this
this whole network is around team
science and this is a great if you ever
thought about
team science before you went to get
involved this is a great opportunity to
do that
it gives you access to other experts
like so if we don't have certain experts
here
there are experts in the community um
it's also a great opportunity to learn
i've learned a lot since i've been on
this effort here i didn't know a lot
about in
machine learning and some of the other
deep learning tools and i'm beginning to
learn more about that so this is a great
opportunity to learn other analytic
methods and processes
so i think for ohsu this this is also a
great opportunity
to you know develop and grow a diverse
you know workforce and also for us you
know to help with our career advancement
opportunities
um so you can participate on you know as
far as research you can participate on
community research teams that have been
established already and i'll go through
those the main teams in a moment
um as i mentioned before there's there's
a large opportunity here to learn
learn about the different types of data
models um learn about machine learning
and other
statistical methods there there are
domain groups around methods so if you
want to learn about methods
you want to you know see what people
think about your methods this is a great
opportunity to do that
but one thing i think is interesting um
is that it's a great opportunity to work
with healthcare data
so at many institutions um they always
talk about well
there's a research group and there's a
healthcare group side of things and we
don't always get access to the to the
ehr data we don't have access to that so
we can't really do a lot of research
well here you get to actually use ehr
data and not only are you using
ehr data but you're using ehr data from
multiple institutions
which is unique because data is
different from data
different places so you get to kind of
see how things work differently
large scale um it's a great opportunity
for us here at ohsu to build
training programs or participate in
training programs and partner
partner with other groups and provide a
research experience
for for our trainees and and and not
just maybe for
research purposes but if we want
training programs for staff
we want smaller projects like might be
you know a one or two month project for
a class this can be an opportunity to do
that
another way um this can actually help
with advancement opportunities
and developing a workforce is is the
networking aspect
aspect of it so we have access
you know to other ctsa programs but
other experts across the country a lot
of people who are involved in this
effort are not
all who are not involved in ctsas um
they come from other universities
and and they have this expertise so it's
a great opportunity if you don't have
the
expertise here for something you want to
do you might be able to collaborate with
someone else to help you on this
research project
and you guys might be able to get
something um submitted together
so a little bit more about team science
so we do have these teams
and as i was mentioning before that
these teams are made up of a diverse
group
um we have people with different
backgrounds you know yes statisticians
on them
people who have expertise in study
design so if you have a research
question it might be a good way to get
feedback on the study design and
evaluation
you have you have informatics experts
but also clinicians are part of these
domain teams as well
so if you may not have a particular
clinical expert
you know readily available you might be
able to go to one of these domain teams
and get their input
on research designs um there are also
people who are involved from
um commercialization groups um former
groups are participating
and and other um in another in other
types of communities as well and there's
also the technical
aspect to this group so there are people
who have expert in the enclave itself
so a lot of people think that okay i'm
gonna get access to this data
and i'm gonna start doing research well
the enclave is
not that easy to use you see any fair
warning it takes a little bit of time to
get used to it's different
and you may need technical expertise to
help you with that and so
joining these domain groups will give
you access to chemical experts
who who know how to use the data they
understand
omap um they have no they understand
technologies and terminologies
they can help you understand what the
data is and is not
um if you need a code set developed you
can get help with
um with that at the same time this could
be an opportunity
you know to to actually grow smaller
groups
have smaller groups and do smaller team
science
have a smaller team science
opportunities as well
and so a little bit more about clinical
domain teams um you can find
more information on the npc website but
we have these clinical domain teams
um that have been established they're
probably about
18 to 20 of them they're growing these
have been organically
created by the community they see a need
they get together they ask others to
join and they start doing research
and so this is just a list of some of
the domain teams that are available
that are out there now um some are more
active than others
um if there's not one out there that
meets your needs you can definitely
create your own domain team um people
are very collaborative
when it comes to these teams and the
latest one that has been established
um is the machine learning um domain
team led by peter robinson from
jackson labs uh he's he sent out
i think their meeting on thursdays and
you go to the website to find more
information about
about this particular domain team um but
there's a lot of interest in machine
learning in fact
i think the last time i heard this
morning that 62 people already signed up
for this domain teams there's a lot of
excitement around machine learning
so if you do participate in a domain
team
um there are some resources to help
support you
and so um some of the some of the data
that you need access to may require an
irb
and so if it requires an irb the domain
teams can get together
and come up with a a common irb
approach so that way you can get things
through your irb and submit
faster um also there's an environment
for collaboration
we use um google platform for that and
so there are documents that are out
there where you swap
um we establish email listservs
uh we publish the meetings through the
calendar we send out
announcements you know about the
meetings but more so than just the
logistics
you know for that there's shared
resources
so if you need a code set developed um
or anything like that
you might be able to share code um we
share resources across the domain teams
so someone already created a code set or
created a resource
on one domain team they can share it
with you so that way
you don't have to re recreate the will
so these are and as i mentioned there
are quite a few projects that already
have already started and so you can find
a list of projects on the website
um most of the projects you can join as
a collaborator there are some projects
that
are closed right now to collaborators
they may be just starting or they're
trying to get themselves organized
but we encourage we encourage projects
to have open
um project to be open and allow
collaborators to join
and and most of them are and so if you
want to see a list you can go out to the
website
and as it was mentioned we do have osu
is participating in at least
two maybe three projects um so david
ellison from oak tree is participating
on aki
and pediatrics um project and as i
mentioned before
we have a student here who's
participating who has
his own project he's lead investigator
for his home project so
this is where ohsu is participating i
think they're also participating in some
of the synthetic um
projects too this is an example of a
domain team here
um cherise matlock has done a wonderful
job with social determinants of health
it's been a very popular domain team and
um what she's done she's brought
together community of experts
who are interested in understanding
social determinants of health around
covert 19.
what makes her team actually unique is
that they weren't the very first ones
who also
um mentioned um you know that we want to
bring in external data sets
and so she has had hackathons and things
like that to get people
um up to speed so um this is just an
example of a group
who's already started to do some
research and start to look at some of
the things that are in
in covet 19 data and hope they hope to
publish soon
so um other examples of opportunities
for researchers here at oyster shoe
like i said mentioned learn to work with
large-scale ehr
data it's a good opportunity to
understand common models and how to work
with them so i think as we
you know as we start to move forward in
research especially getting data from
ehrs
we're gonna have to learn how to work
with commonwealth a lot more so this may
be an opportunity to start doing that
also develop skills um to create
organize
and run um cross-discipline teams
and also maybe learn things like um
predictive analysis
so you're saying okay i don't have a
project i'm not
you know i don't have a research
question but i like to get involved
well no problem there are so many other
activities you can actually participate
in
and so um the data liaison role is a
role as something newly created
um and it's people who are comfortable
with data
and this is to really help the domain
teams is to help them understand ehr
data because a lot of clinicians and
researchers don't really understand ehr
data
and so a data liaison can let people
know like what normally is found in ehr
data and what's not
so this is a great opportunity here too
also to
um identify and create code sets um
help with linkedin linkages to other
data sets and help the domain teams
curate data
data elements
and the reason why i mentioned this is
because um
with data harmonization um we have to
create the code sets
they didn't come intact so if
their code tests have been developed but
if you have like if you have a stroke
study and you need to understand the
symptoms of stroke you might have to
create the code set
for stroke symptoms and so someone has
to do that and so that's what the group
is doing now creating these code sets
that can be shared with the rest of the
community
so another group another if so if you
want if you're interested
about opportunities for for
participating and
um and i would say joining a
collaborative analytics group is a way
to do that
i mean you can join any of these groups
here um
you know where if you're interested in
government governance and policies
feel free to join those groups um the
phenotype
data acquisition and data ingestion
harmonization if you're interested in
you know data models you know and
research around that you can definitely
join that but collaborative analytics is
where i think most people are probably
going to be interested in if they want
to know more about
nlp methods and practices um use of
different types of analytics
um and research around that these are
opportunities here
and i would suggest to seek out those
groups and also synthetic data
so there's a lot of interest about
synthetic data the nih is interested in
it
um there is um fda has shown a lot of
interest in synthetic data
and then other organizations other
universities have contacted me
and said you know we would like to use
synthetic data too but we wanted to use
it also for educational purposes
and so they're trying to figure out ways
um best ways to develop programs around
using synthetic data for for um training
purposes
um as well as here at what you should
look into that um
what the nih is interested in this and
they wouldn't move forward with it but
as i mentioned before
that they're wanting to get the data
validated first before they open it up
and just see what comes out of
it and they're different they're
different companies who create synthetic
data
so we're working with one company now
but the other companies are working with
certain also
generate synthetic data and so there's
an effort to look at those different
companies
and kind of evaluate those their methods
and
processes around synthetic data and
generation words
so if you're interested in synthetic
data if you have questions about
synthetic data
they do meet monthly but they have
office hours and you're welcome to join
our office hours
ask questions about synthetic
um other areas as i mentioned if you're
interested in nlp
there's a group that's working on
methods for nlp um they're a national
group that was established before they
joined in
in 3c um and we're planning to
change the protocol in order to get more
text data so we can
run some nlp on it um but they're right
now
um designing their methods so if you're
interested in participating in that
effort
um i would suggest to seek them out as
well
and other opportunities um justin reese
from lawrence berkeley labs is working
on knowledge graphs so if you're
interested in knowledge graphs this
is showing different examples of
different opportunities that are
available in sys1
this is not my area so i probably can't
answer any questions about knowledge
graph grass look over it
um sage bionet is one of the groups
that is has dream challenges going on
right now
so they have students um and some
faculty members who are involved in this
and doing research i think like the
university of alabama had a large effort
around dream challenges for their
organization so if you're looking for
opportunities
um you know to join other groups or to
test
anything i was i was just seeking out
what they're doing and participating
one of the things that i i wouldn't just
point out and this is important
um many times the people who
are published are going to be lead
investigators or clinicians
we truly believe that it does take a
village
it takes all of us to make this happen
and therefore everybody
who's participating should receive
acknowledgement and attribution
so the enclave is set up that if you're
participating
and developing any of the artifacts that
are going to be used in publications
then you should be recognized too and so
we're building an infrastructure within
the enclave in order to
track that information so that way you
can get credit and attributions
automatically
attributed to you for anything that you
create
and anything that might be shared with
other groups so
um so this means that anybody who's a
statistician
or informaticist or somebody's working
machine learning
um anybody who's working in this should
be able to get attribution so that
that's
really important uh we also have the
enclaves set up for
um for reproducibility
so if you're re if you have something
you're published
some of the journals now are asking for
information on reproducibility
the enclave is set up to do that to
reproduce the results
and we're working on now how to get
those reports designed
so that way that can be that can be
provided so that way when you are
submitting to lancet or anyone of those
that you can have that kind of report
um so you can get into those high impact
journals
so i just want to mention just
providence um and also ability to share
information
within the enclave
um one thing i want to point out are the
different data levels
so all data is the same in the enclave
but what you see could be different
so as i mentioned synthetic data the
synthetic data is putting the pilot
there's de-identified data that's also
available
and there's also what's called a limited
data set so the limited data set
just has some dates and some zip codes
in there if you do
use limited data set or if you need a
limited data set you do have to have irb
approval
and you have to justify why you have to
have a limited data set
and why the de-identified data will not
work so i just want to let you know that
when you get resubmit your your
request for data so but these are the
different levels most people
if you think that you may eventually use
them as a data set
i would still suggest using the
de-identified or requested de-identified
anyway first
because when you're working on a
research team everyone may not be able
to get their irb approvals at the same
time and you probably want to start
at the same time so my recommendation is
to
apply for de-identified data to get
started and then once
the majority of your team members have
received irb approval from their
institutions
then you can do submit for limited data
set you guys can all move up together
all right getting access to the data so
ohsu you can get access to the ehr data
um and so because the dua is in place
but you'll have to register
um to get access and there's there's two
things you want to do you want to access
you want access to the data but you also
want access to the documents and
supporting documents
um and so you want to sign up for that
you also have to have training
um and you and the data use requests
will ask you for your dates to training
so your city training you have to
provide the dates for your city training
and then nih also requires you that you
have to have some kind of in a security
training
so you have to take that so my
recommendation is there's a checklist
on the hl7 i mean there's a checklist on
the
n3c website and i can or i can send it
to you if you ask me
and they'll tell you everything you need
to do and i would suggest going through
that checklist first before actually
submitting your dur
because once you go into the data use
request form electronically in the
enclave
um you can't get past providing the
information
so it's best to go ahead and get all
that in place first and then submit it
um and once you get once you submit it
um you get your account set up um to
bring enclave
and then you submit your request for the
research project it just has to go
through the data access
now if you're a collaborator you're
welcome to join existing projects
and so if you want to as a collaborator
join you can
and there's a slightly still to fill out
i did a use request for that but you can
actually join as a collaborator
um you won't have to go through the data
access committee for that
unless it is lds data and then it's not
really going through data access
it's just somebody just making sure that
you have your irb um documents in place
so go out to the website if you want to
register there's a button there says
access to the enclave
you'll fill out a form but it might be a
little tricky because
when you click on that button um you
actually will see this
um and so what it is is like an
authenticator um because
we want to make sure people's email
addresses are are
accurate and so what you'll do is you'll
sign into this here you'll see ohsu
that pop up and you click on the or
tissue icon it's not showing here but
you click up on that voice issue icon
and that's how you'll once you do that
and authenticate through oh she oh hsu
then you can actually sign
in to um to um
to be on sign in to request an account
for the entree
and and then the forms um there are
the resources available on the web page
we are going to restructure this
i would love to get your feedback so
much of this has been like
so fast you threw things up there things
may not be
um as easy to find as they probably
should be because things happen so
quickly
but if um we would love to have people
to give us
feedback on you know ways to redesign
this better so it's easier for
researchers to find information they
need
but we do have some information that's
out there government documents the
governance documents
access of the main teams and things like
that if you need it
and just to let you know we do have a
publication already
um we have the um the manuscript about
our methods
it's a methods manuscript and so there's
a link there if you want to read more
about
what we're doing um the one thing i just
want to say is that we are trying to
make sure that whatever we do is is
definitely reproducible
and if you have a question feel free to
contact me directly
which is no i get lots of questions from
around the country
so i may not always get to your email
fast enough the best thing to do if you
have a question
is to go to the support desk page and
just
you know submit a report submit a
question but we also have our
office hours so we do have someone who
is available on tuesdays and thursdays
who can answer your questions about
anything concerning the enquiry we'll
have
orientation for research teams and
researchers
coming soon um but this is i always say
but if you have a question doesn't
matter what kind of question it is
don't hesitate to submit a request we
usually review these
um every day um and i review them on
thursdays to make sure
things have been answered addressed um
and i'm just going to pause
there and see if we have any
questions there's some
there's a few there actually there are
more comments there's a little dialogue
going on in the question box um
one question came up about other disease
phenotypes which i know is probably
beyond the scope of n3c but is
has there been any discussion of that i
i mentioned the
uh precision medicine project which is
now called all of us which
many of us heard about yesterday in the
closing session of the amia meeting
um are you aware of any other activities
or is this project really focused on
covet 19.
this particular project is focused on
copenhagen
but right i was going to mention all of
us as another one um
so i think i think as far as
methods for how what nh will do in the
future
we'll they'll they're going to look at
all of us and they're going to look at
n3c to determine
you know will we do something similar um
based on those programs for other
disease areas
all the information i have about what's
happening right now everything's focused
on kovic right now
and and that question of linkage uh came
up uh
in josh denny's talk yesterday in fact i
was one of several people who asked it
um are there um this is a great talk
and it's a really nice um overview of
n3c
and i hope um um you know people who are
interested will
will consider any questions from um
the audience out here or um you can
either unmute yourself or
continue typing in the in the box
here we go a question about accessing
the
data enclave for someone who's not
associated with ohsu but with a
different institution
so yes if um you can access
anybody it's open to anybody um
regardless if they're here or just you
or not
if they're with another institution they
want to check to see if their
institution
has a dua in place and you can go to the
website there's a link
and maybe i can put it in chat um if i
stop sharing hold on
um i can put in chat and you can
actually go out there and see if your
institution is a dua
they don't have a dua you can encourage
them to work with ncats to get a dua
in place there are a couple of people
who
um don't work with an institution there
there's
they're they're independent
investigators and so they still have to
sign a dua as an independent
investigators but incats really prefers
that the institution exercise
okay another question from homer chen
how does this relate to
other projects like pcornet
so the member members from the cornet
um trinetics at all of those
all those groups are participating here
in n3c
they're part of the the data
harmonization teams
um and data quality teams they helped us
up this infrastructure because they know
their data models better than we do
so they're all participating in this um
i think everybody
everybody is um has their own
initiatives as well
around covet and this is a supplement to
those initiatives
but they're all participating with us
because this is a centralized approach
so is uh so i know that picornet's data
model is one of the four
that you ingest um and then it's up to
the institution
to choose if say they want to take their
pcornet data
and um put it into the enclave
right so we do have institutions i think
there's a report there's a report there
was there is a corporate initiative
around coba too
and some of those institutions are
providing their data to their
their um to that network and as well as
ours which makes it easy for them
they're not doing
you know we do the work so they are
sending the same data to us
there is going to be a slight change
there's going to be a meeting a
symposium
and i think in january because the covet
data
across these models is different um and
we know a lot more about
covet now and so and some of the data
models don't carry
all of the data that's needed for covid
so there's gonna be enough symposium in
no
in in january about additional
information that's going to be needed
that the data models are not providing
um that we're going to need in order to
really do more robust
research around it
there's a question from nicole about um
opportunities for students um should
they go through their advisors or should
they be encouraged to join independently
um i would suggest they talk to their
advisors um
they can they can come to us certainly
independently but they go through their
advisors it might help them
determine where they might best fit um
in the m3c
organization whether if they have a
research question how best to
address that research question um if
they are seeking other types of
experiences um they can do that if they
would like for me
to help them think about it um i'm used
to working with a bunch of different
students
to give them all kinds of experiences
you know for informatics and
then i hire them so um so
if but i always say talk to their they
should talk to their advisor first
um and i'll be happy to join just to let
them know
what the opportunities look like and
what kind of support they might be able
to get
um through n3c and and just so you know
i'm throwing this out there
but um we probably will need some you
know
student help either you know part-time
um to help us with some
product this could apply to their
projects with their learning
um but we we probably will be hiring
someone um temporary for
maybe six months to a year to help us
out with some things
yeah and i i would probably advise
students to if nothing else just to let
their
advisors know um and and there you know
there may be opportunities
you know for example um you know to get
um independent study
you know research kind of credit and so
forth so
um um students probably should work for
their advisors
let me ask another question so um
this past week we heard about 70 000
people who participated in vaccine
trials i suppose very few of them
actually though
have symptomatic cope at 19 but any
thoughts of putting
their data into the enclave yes we are
having discussions around that now
about um the vaccine data and um so
we we did take a look there is some
vaccine information
in the enclave um but we are trying to
figure out a strategy
in order to increase more information
from the different time sites um for for
that
also we're imagining that all the data
all the vaccine information may not be
going through the hospitals
they may be going through the community
clinics and places like that so we're
trying to figure out ways
to engage with those community clinics
to see if we're able to get vaccine
information that way as well
ocean ocean is one of the groups that
just join um
in 3c and so we will have um data
hopefully
through ochen which will be great for
those of us at ohsu but we're hoping to
also have more
um community hospitals to contribute but
right now we don't know if
all that information is in the academic
medical center
ehr data um but when it is we are
getting that data
that is that's that's a hot topic right
now as you can
imagine
any other questions
well okay i am i want to thank you for
um an interesting and informative talk
um
as i think people can tell i have a lot
of enthusiasm for this project as well
um and it's great that you know a
significant part of it is occurring
at ohsu so um
uh thanks a lot anita and and someday
when we go back
to working in person you can come visit
the department
and and meet us face to face and
get to know us that way as well i'd be
like
okay thank you everyone and um uh we'll
see you at the next
uh conference